this Halloween I was thinking about
putting a big slice of ham over my body
and and cutting it out to look like a
ghost and then I would be a Gaba
goul that would be fine because I'm of
Italian extraction that would not be
cultural appropriation but beware
because the forces of wokeness are out
there to call you a racist if you picked
the wrong costume so we've got
instructions for white people on what
they're supposed to do for Halloween
this video is brought to you by genus
right now go to J cell.com
nsyt ticktockers take it away for
Halloween make sure your costume isn't
racist that means of course no
blackace all right yeah of course no
using accents that are from people of
color in black and Indigenous
communities no taping your eyes back no
wearing of indigenous spiritual
andcultural wear so those are some
guidelines for costumes put a pause
there the the thing is if you dress up
like a demon or a devil or something
like that you would be wearing
indigenous spiritual wear because a lot
of these indigenous D tribes just
worship demons so uh that one's going to
be hard though I I don't really get into
all that stuff I don't want to dress up
like a devil on Halloween still a lot of
people do that and if you do you would
be culturally appropriative according to
this person this white devil thing has
gone far enough but also just don't be
racist for the rest of the year either
don't be racist racism is the worst
thing nothing is worse than racism if
you do anything bad you're
racist the word racist of course means
nothing though if if wearing a fun
little Halloween costume if if wearing a
sombrero on Halloween makes you a racist
then racism doesn't mean anything other
than anything a white person does that a
non-white person wants to object to
that's all it is it's even the very term
racism is just a way to tell white
people to to shut up and and to say that
all white people are bad that's
basically all it's about that's
especially true on Halloween next one my
monster from his slab began to rise and
suddenly to my surprise he did the he
did the mon put a pause there you know
I'm a married man
okay okay when I was a young single man
I would have found that costume
very fun not to wear but for for my
female friends to wear that would have
been I I don't see very much wrong with
that costume other than that it's
immodest it CAU on in a
flag obviously no blackface costumes
I'll probably get in trouble for asking
this why not why not why is that that's
then that's obviously the one you why
not is that blackface dude get the out
man one time I was in LA I was in an
Uber and I could tell that the driver
who was a black guy was conservative and
there was one of these blackface
scandals that cropped up and I said what
do you think about that and he said oh
man I don't care about blackface he said
as long as it's in good fun you know
it's just part of the fun of things
which is such a an insightful
observation if you're wearing a a
culturally appropriative costume uh
because you hate some other race and you
want to mock them and insult them and
you you just want to be cruel to them
then I yeah I guess that's a bad thing
but if you're just wearing the costume
of another culture and it's kind of fun
and celebratory who cares seems fine to
me sure I'll be canceled for that but
what can I say it's the way I see it
it's no secret that here at the daily
wire we all love speaking of our faces
genus L Dark Spot Corrector you might be
asking what does this product even do
well we've all got sunspots brown spots
discoloration or dry skin with the genus
Cell Dark Spot Corrector you can watch
these blemishes disappear in front of
your very eyes Kimberly from Young Ohio
says my appearance has improved so much
since using genus cell on my face I love
all my genus cell products and my skin
looks younger now it's your turn to feel
like Kimberly but this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
genus cell bags and puffy treatment and
immediate effects off for almost 70% off
Jus cell is so confident in their
products that you can try them for
yourself completely risk-free if you
don't see results in one day you will
get your money back it's very simple go
to genucell.com
nsy T letter y letter T start looking
years even decades younger tomorrow say
hello to the best skin you've ever had
at Jas cell.com
nsyt letter y letter T jus.com
nsyt keep going now before you go
planning your Halloween costume it's
time to educate and activate and today
we are talking about cultural
appropriation this is the unacknowledged
or inappropriate adoption of Customs
practices or ideas of one cultural group
by members of another cultural group
usually a more dominant cultural group
and this is not to be confused with with
true cultural exchange which is
typically gifted from the non-dominant
cultural group The flows of power
recognize the systemic rtier of certain
homes and forced into boarding schools
where they are forced to when they da
Mass produce headresses shows to namaste
in bed shirts remember culture is not a
costume so go have a fun safe and
respectful
Halloween culture is not a costume I
wonder what this lady
thinks of Kate Jenner I want to keep
this video on social media so I'm just
going to leave that question here if you
say culture is not a costume my identity
is not your C I wonder what this lady
thinks about
that next one in appropriate Halloween
costume check this just feels wrong why
culture is not a costume a costume okay
culture is not a costume I know that
these people deny that white people have
any kind of culture whatsoever but we
have the dominant culture in the west
obviously so would the principle hold
for a non-white person to wear I don't
know a leprechaun outfit you know
something associated with the Irish or
to dress up like Mario Mario and Luigi
would that be cultural appropriation
what if a black kid put on a three
Corner hat and said that he was George
Washington crossing the Delaware oh God
would that be evil would that be
terrible why does it only ever go in one
direction for one group of people that
aren't owed to do anything aab aab aab
aab aab aab aab aab aab aab is a woman
having a stroke
aab black facing try dying try dying wow
if you dress up in a way that she
doesn't like she wants you dead and then
she said AAP aab is that a that's an
anti-cop thing all cops are bad I don't
think it means what do you think it
means that's one of the the famous final
utterances of people before they're
attacked by criminals in cities where
the cops have been told not to do their
jobs she seems to have she seems to have
a lot of issues she doesn't need to
worry about the costume the facade she
needs to worry about what's going on
inside the most enlightening of these
videos I'm going to have to say was not
this one what was the one before this I
got a kick out of her I I would say hers
the woman in the low cut yellow hoodie
hers was the most enlightening for me
because it lulled me to sleep and so I
got a couple minutes of peace and quiet
in my deck
where I I didn't have to be consciously
[Music]
aware and so for that reason she gets
the
award we all we all got that little
award nice little break see you next
[Music]
time
oh